this Jonah Hill story we covered this
yesterday I'm just going to read a bit
from the daily wire Jonah Hill's Surfer
ex-girlfriend Sarah Brady released a
number of text messages she said were
attempts to control her behavior Hill
explained what he expected of her with
regard to the way she presented herself
if they were going to be dating
seriously one of the texts read plain
and simple if you need surfing with men
boundaryless inappropriate relationships
with men to model to post pictures of
yourself in a bathing suit to post
sexual pictures friendships with women
who are in unstable places and from your
wild recent past Beyond getting a lunch
or coffee or something respectful I am
not the right partner for you if these
things bring you to a place of happiness
I support it and there will be no hard
feelings these are my boundaries for a
romantic partnership my boundaries which
with you based on the way these actions
have hurt our trust Spencer let me start
with you on this one when I read this
yesterday I was like man not only is
everything he said there completely
within bounds even if someone was
arguing that to some degree okay he
doesn't want her to model maybe that's
like for somebody maybe that's a bit
much he was being clear and honest about
what he wants and it seems to me that
that is what young people need more than
anything these days no one is setting
boundaries no one's saying what they
want and understanding what they believe
to even say it in the first place I I
thought it was beautiful and of course
the media is now calling him a
misogynist and the rest of it right
right I mean this was a real mask off
moment because he's doing everything
that men are constantly being told to do
he's being forthright and clear about
his hopes for the relationship he's
doing so in a respectful way he's using
language pulled right out of a therapy
session I mean these are my boundaries
he's effectively attempting to just
reach out to this woman in and and say
in the plainest terms possible I want a
committed relationship with you I don't
want to be competing between myself and
the internet essentially for your
affections for your love all of these
things I'm sure that that came along
with you know a corresponding commitment
on on his end and she's spits this in
his face as like a form of abuse the
metoo movement has now cratered in on
itself from uh sort of understandable
Creed occur against rampant abuses in
Hollywood into like somebody said a man
sent me a text basically what all of
these complaints now amount to is
somebody hit on me and I wasn't into it
because the real secret behind all of
this is if you are if you have chemistry
with somebody and if you're flirting and
you're getting along and you're figuring
out a healthy way to build a
relationship together none of this stuff
is even remotely toxic who counts even
slightly as abuse the message that this
sends to me that this scent I think to a
lot of young men is there is nothing you
can do being a man is the crime and
therefore if you attempt anything at any
moment even if you don't say anything at
all if you just sit there ultimately you
are liable for some kind of exposure uh
for for shaming for for public abuse and
this is a completely untenable
unsustainable situation men and women of
Goodwill all know it the sexual ethic of
this neo-feminist movement is totally
played out totally could put something
better has to replace it and what's
interesting to me is that something
better quietly and secretly is replacing
it if you talk to young people
especially young women they know that
this stuff is junk it has destroyed
their lives it has set men and women
against each other when they should be a
delight unto one another and much like
the situation in Hollywood it simply
can't last reality is certain facts
about reality just come back around and
one of them is that men and women aren't
in a war they're not fundamentally
dollars to another manhood is not a
crime and I I think the Jonah Hill thing
was really revealing to people not
necessarily on the right who just said
look what does this guy have to do he's
doing everything he's supposed to uh
being totally clear and forthright and
he's still getting burned for it
something's got to give